and we're live
getting that nodey and getting the
people in the chat
there it is
hello hello hello hello and here we go
isaac what's up that canadian raccoon
what's up
game time adam butler what's up my dude
always coming in sassy pants what's up
what is up everybody we got a lot to
talk about today
i think my
yep chris talk so i can tell um
testing
oh yeah no i can hear you cool what is
up everybody
excuse me we'll have to uh
i'm using both mics here one to talk to
chris
hi and uh
one to talk to y'all um we will talk
about that for those asking when i think
the new way home trailer is going to
drop we're
that's what this is for uh we're going
to do live shows each week
this is chris hi i'm chris
that's chris from cosmic culture
if you guys haven't subscribed to
cosmculture yet you should that's our
other channel
uh venom 2 trailer guys
that looks like that was pretty
inaccurate i guess yeah all right i
guess they're still like
what two days left no this is it hey
adam thanks for the super chat i guess
yeah right
doing well how are you doing oh yeah we
talked about it last week you're right
yeah so today is the last day
of april yeah
i would expect it soon hey jake heads
thanks so much for that
super chat appreciate that i hope you're
doing well hope you're doing well
as well um
so let's okay let's just go ahead and
start talking about the venom 2 trailer
um
that was from daniel rbk
i believe um i actually
texted him um
let's like a few days ago or a day ago
or something like that and i was just
kind of like
you know what did you really hear about
it and he said he just heard soon
and he presumed it was by the end of the
month so
it could be the very beginning it could
be any day now i mean really right
we're just waiting for it i guess we'll
just wake up one day and there'll be a
trailer
and that's pretty much what's going to
happen so morbius got delayed today i'm
not sure who
you know who all saw that but today
morbius got delayed
now nothing for spider-man
or venom has been said yet um
and it's really interesting because i
feel like
i feel like a lot of theaters are open
back up
and i feel like i don't know i just feel
like it's
i felt like we were past pushing things
back
but i guess we're not well i guess we're
still waiting to finalize
because movies aren't just waiting to
see when they're coming out they're
waiting to see what other movies are
coming out to see they have to go up
against
so you know you never know venom's like
hey we're waiting to find out when
this movie's coming out so that it's not
pushed the weekend we're releasing
they're all playing this game against
each other like
i i guess we have to wait kind of
i think black widow might be like the
defining factor because they're going to
release her
in disney or on disney plus and in
theaters so maybe
some people are are waiting just a
little bit but
we'll have to see as far as sony is
concerned they just pushed back morbius
um they pushed it back a week though so
they didn't really like
that could be some sort of a scheduling
conflict that they had i don't think
that's actually because of cobit
covid um so i think we can expect
the venom trailer i want to say within
the next
couple of weeks based off of everything
that we've heard
so yeah so next thing we'll talk about
because everybody wants to know
is the spider-man no way home trailer
because
right i think it was it was yesterday
uh yeah yesterday grace randolph came
out and she said
that she heard the trailer is coming out
in june or july
which means we have well which means we
potentially have a month
right that could be a teaser or a full
trailer no it's
it's gonna be a teaser um yeah for sure
they're not gonna start us off
no but here's here's my question to
everybody in the chat right now and to
you chris
when we get the teaser because i do
believe we are going to get a teaser
first
is there any mention of any other
spider-man's
or you know showing something like maybe
like three
you know like three sets of feet
right like you know something like that
right three sets of like feet that have
like the spiderman
you know webbing on and stuff like that
i was gonna say
most we're gonna get something extremely
subtle that
can't necessarily be proved i don't
think we see
any other spider-man maybe not even in
the first full trailer but
i think in the first full trailer
they'll they'll tease it
i think they might tease it yeah but
there's no way in the teaser trailer we
get that we might get some of these
villains that we're hearing are coming
over like doc ock or
electro we might get to see some of that
but i don't know yeah uh no tracker
thanks for that super chat yes they are
as far as when we don't have like an
official date yet but sony and
disney yeah sony and disney just made
that deal
which is insanely good
it's absolutely good for marvel in
general
because from what i've been hearing it's
not just
it's not jus like it's not just a simple
deal as
simple as like you can take our care you
know you can take our movies and you can
put them on disney plus now
uh it's not as simple as that because
you know before it was kind of like
netflix and everything
so now it's a little bit more there's a
little bit more to it than that like now
it's
hey you can kind of take our stuff and
put it on disney plus and
also take some of our characters yeah
it's more of a merging
and have a little bit more freedom with
um than you've had in the past
hey stopped away thanks for that super
chat says what up chris and warren
hope you're doing well today okay so i
see a few people talking about the
you know what deal in uh in the chat and
that's basically the deal there's a new
deal between sony and marvel
uh disney right because they own marvel
stating that
they can now put spider-man movies on
disney plus which is like a really
really big deal
um you know far from home wasn't on
there and
really what the big deal is
is that sony and disney are continuing
to play nice
continuing to kind of give each other a
little bit more sony is giving
more and more and more right as we
excuse me as we've went through
the start before civil war came out and
everybody like
spider-man's gonna be in captain
america's civil war and everyone's like
no they're not no he's not because
that's sony and blah blah blah blah
when it turns out obviously he was and
that was a deal that they made and so
we've gone from that
to and that was a that was a three that
was a three
movie deal four movie deal and we've
gone from that
to the scare where we didn't know tom
hall if tom holland was actually going
to be
from the mcu or not right which was like
a huge scare and that's all that we can
we could talk about at that time candace
ram edge thank you so much for that
super chat appreciate that um
and to now you know it's good it went
from that to hey you know now
spider-man's going to do you know like
three more movies and he's going to do
like a uh a group
film which is going to be like avengers
right and now it's like hey
here have some spider-man right pretty
much like
and that's gonna be like so think about
it instead of giving like netflix or
another streaming service that money
for the spider-man films are giving it
to disney which is an incredibly good
sign
no yeah that definitely shows that they
have a lot of faith primarily in the
character
which we've seen from you know the fans
and people we talk to daily
a lot of love for spider-man oh a ton of
love for spider-man
so i don't think he's going away anytime
soon because these companies are here to
make money and spider-man is probably
the single most individual character
that they can cash in the most
oh absolutely and if you think about it
look how much they're expanding for
spider-man
like there's rumors about a miles
morales film coming out you know or like
him coming out and
and hey i don't think so much for chris
yeah he'll totally get it
this one's for chris yeah i don't know
um they're doing so much with spider-man
right now
like the whole sp umc which i i still
hate
sony pictures universal yeah hopefully
we're just kind of getting rid of that
too hopefully they get rid of that yep
so the whole spmc is really really
expanding they have really big plans
with that um
so frank grillo has signed on for like
five more movies i think
what do you think those could be if he
ever comes back thanks for that don't
know no tracker well i think the captain
america franchise is going to actually
be pretty big moving forward
um maybe maybe some flashbacks like
uh he's he's clearly like dead right i
mean
yeah let's let's see something real fast
no he's not popping up if i like go to
imdb and like
anything like that but um
it's got to be something i mean so
here's the deal with the new captain
america movie i hope it's set in the
past or i'm sorry there's two new
captain america movies coming out
with the one with chris evans that's
rumored to be about chris evans captain
america
if he goes back in the past then that's
you know one area for frank grillo to
show up
and depending on how many movies they do
with that sometimes they just sign them
in case they need them
right because look at aaron uh
[Music]
taylor johnson not peter taylor yeah
aaron taylor john i almost said aaron
peters
aaron taylor johnson they signed him and
he only
fulfilled one of his con
one of his movies which was like a three
i think it was a three movie contract
i believe and you know maybe it'll come
back in the future but maybe they just
lock people down sometimes and then
things kind of take like
a different direction so
but getting back to the the trailer
grace randolph who
you know i don't i don't really have
anything bad to say about grace you know
sometimes her scoops don't come through
and
i think that happens but she's been
right about a lot and she's like
tight with zack snyder and she's
interviewed some really famous people so
she clearly has connections somehow
right
so i don't doubt that she has
connections and she says it's coming out
in june or july which if you line it up
makes sense
right right it's like eight months out
that's a good teaser trailer
a couple months later to the main
trailer and then you have another
trailer after that and a crap ton of tv
spots because we know that that's what
marvel loves to do
not to mention they did that for
spider-man far from home there's like a
new tv spot every day it was like a
vendor's end game
uh no tracker thank us thanks again for
the
super shot i want a movie with him
returning the stones yeah i think
everybody wants to see what happens i
think everybody wants to see
that happen and i think there's a pretty
decent possibility that
if they made another movie with chris
evans as captain america which is
rumored to happen
that we could see at least some of that
i'm not saying that the whole movie
would be about that
but well i think they left a nice little
teaspoon too when they're like you want
to tell us about what happened he's like
no i don't think i will
right because i'm getting a movie in two
years
yeah marvel you so at kev kevin feige
like
six months ago i can't remember
oh um it was like six months ago he said
you know with everything that we already
have
planned like what they've announced
marvel phase four and all that stuff
they have like six years ahead past that
oh yeah there's so many projects we
don't know about
and then like i did a video on the other
day
uh malcolm spellman uh
writer and head for falcon and winter
soldier slash the new captain america
movie that's coming out
was like i was surprised how much
unannounced things
marvel has as in there's a ton of
content
projects that they have that they
haven't announced yet which doesn't
surprise me at all
my question is how the heck are you
gonna fit it all in like
a year like we already have three movies
and three shows
minimum it's most likely going to be
four movies and four shows coming out
that's a lot of thursdays for me to stay
up all night
um uh clg comics i appreciate that
thanks for that super chat
somebody said we're handsome handsome
thank you
or wait what we're hands oh that's what
i thought i was like
me too me too you too i'm also handsome
i agree chris is handsome
do super mario simones
that what that says i have a favorite
mcu movie yeah uh
wait are you gonna make a definitive
statement right now that's what that's
why i stopped
i don't know i don't know if i want to
make a definitive statement
definitive statement he refuses i can't
make a definitive statement
i think overall infinity war is my
favorite
um best experience was
in game and besides the huge you know
infinity award and
game that love uh thor loving thunder
thor ragnarok is my favorite
uh candace rambis thanks for another
super chat i've been really wanting
the captain america shield entered when
you all announce it uh we are going to
announce it probably
that's probably the last thing we're
going to do tonight oh yeah of course
we gotta drag that out hey mr anderson
what up
um shout out to mr anderson for being an
awesome mod um
so back to let's talk about these leaks
that i put in the title because
that's really what we want to talk to
you today for those just joining we are
expecting
the spider-man no way home trailer
according to grace randolph's
insiders in june or july
if you look at all the evidence
in the past about when people drop
trailers how many times in advance
yeah uh it lines up so moving on from
that
let's talk about the leaks that we've
been hearing because we've been hearing
so many leaks and the
the main one i want to talk about is one
i kind of touched on today
uh in my video today is throughout
everything that we've been hearing more
recently because you got to remember
now filming is done for the most part
they're going to do reshoots
and and i'm sure some people still have
some left but tom holland you know
posted the picture filming's done et
cetera et cetera
um so stuff comes out after that because
that's when editing takes place and a
lot of people get involved
doing a lot of different things people
clean up sets and stuff like that
that's how we found that statue of
liberty propaganda poster
with the shield is because it was like
something that was left
and somebody like happened upon it
so norman osborne seems to be one of the
most
common themes in any leak that we've
been getting
norman osborne there's been a few
reports talking about normanoz was going
to be the main villain
but something that's actually been
common in a few different leagues and
this is from like
the hashtag show reporting it this is
from random people on like
reddit and uh what's another website
4chan
posting it going like oh i worked on the
production on the set like this is what
i found like sure okay
like maybe maybe but the common thing is
that
there's going to be two norman osborns
there's going to be willem the foes
coming back which
there was a report i don't want to say
who reported it because i don't remember
but it was from a trade like
the real rejects greg and john look
weird today
i'm gonna assume that's greg what up
greg
which one am i yeah i don't know maybe
what did the hair give it away
yeah mike greg or john john
john has super long hair yeah but maybe
maybe i have greg's teeth
[Laughter]
chris and warren are venom oh that's who
we are okay
so the real rage john and greg will stay
the same but we'll be venom
there you go we'll be the venom version
so here's the big thing about
everything you just lined up for us and
you're 100 right all these links we
research we read about we hear they all
have to do with osborne
a lot of them have to do with two
osborns and the interesting
thing about osborne right we've heard
about
electro we've heard about dr octopus
but osborne changes the game
oh yeah big time these other characters
don't really change the game they're
interesting and it brings a lot of
intrigue like why are they bringing this
character back he's
dead greg stop it greg said you're
definitely john
well there you go i'll be john that's an
honor i'm honored to be john
all right go but um osborne just brings
this whole different aspect to the to
the mcu
and then there's the whole we have two
osborns because the multiverse is going
to be a thing whether they want to admit
it or not right
and it's just absolute game-changing
well and that's
that's what so that's what alfred molina
and jamie foxx's electro did for us they
essentially confirmed the multiverse
right um
and oh hey i know tracker thanks so much
shout out to you guys for the hard work
keep it up
used to watch the latest episodes of
captain america we'll start next morning
breakdown of it hey i appreciate that
well we'll be doing it again for loki
yep
okay coming soon loki coming soon we're
gonna join uh
our thursday nights of rest in the
meantime
um but thank you for that uh so so yeah
what alfred molina's doc awk and
what jamie fox's lecturer did for us
like the confirmation they're gonna be
in it is confirm the multiverse
essentially
so they did that for us but norman
osborne is something that just affects
years down the road it doesn't just
affect the movie
right and so i personally think
since there's going to be two and i
believe that there's going to be two
because there have been reports that
willem dafoe's
norman osborne is going to be in
spider-man no way home
and then there's going to be a new one
excuse me
um i think that what that old avengers
tower is going to be escort
yeah i agree especially if we consider
the fact
well i guess we don't know that the
fantastic four are going to be
introduced in ant-man yet
but if they are and they have been stuck
in in the quantum realm then how can
they have a building
well that's the other thing reed
richards is famously broke
constantly he has you know investors
like uh
doctor doom yeah but he's famously broke
so i don't think he's gonna start off
you know i'm gonna go buy this building
real quick i think
we'll get to the baxter building i
definitely think otherwise
first well it depends because i've heard
you know
non-verified rumors that
this is actually gonna take place like
when they're already married when him
and sue storm are already married and
stuff like that
which i'm all for i don't mind that well
one thing
that i think like sony and marvel did
for
spider-man is they didn't tell the story
that we already knew
ben didn't have to die again right we
know he lost all right we know that ben
parker dies
um and i get that some fans want to see
that i totally understand that
but it's not it really isn't necessary
to tell the story
however you have to think about how much
is necessary for
the story of the fantastic four like
spider-man is arguably
i mean spider-man's up there with batman
and superman right he's one of the most
popular superheroes in the world
oh for sure so everybody really know
like okay he got bit by radioactive
spider right yeah
uh i think everybody knows that yeah his
uncle died that's like the big thing
right uh with the fantastic four yes
they've done movies
um they've done four movies one
in like 19 70 or something i don't
remember
um and then the the jessica alba ones is
i refer to them as
i refer to them as jessica alba
um and then the newer ones um or the
newer one i should say that not a lot of
people enjoyed
but so they've done it before is that
enough well okay you can't count
the second uh just gobble one because
already it's a sequel so
yeah it's continued and then this most
recent one which if i'm being honest i
hadn't even seen yet
there you go heard it was so bad didn't
even didn't even decide to see it
but yeah so the question is do they have
to show them in space
or in the quantum realm or something
like i guess it all depends on what
story they want to tell have they been
stuck in the quantum realm were they
scientists that got stuck in the quantum
realm and that's how they got their
powers just like
for me that's the coolest way to go
about it well especially i think they
set it up with janet van dyne
talking about she developed power right
she developed powers talking about how
it changes you
there was clear oh and hello hello
the the freaking quantum city that they
were talking about now that could be set
up for kang a nihilist but
you know maybe the fantastic four were
there they were in that city and so they
got the powers i mean
and it'd be really cool and it's an easy
way to explain where they've been and
like
just like they do with spider-man that's
a perfect point you bring up you know
they can skip the origin story that
we've already seen in three different
adaptations of this movie right
and it's like hey in the 60s we were a
group of friends who were
you know smart we figured out how to
enter the quantum realm that we couldn't
get back out
and you know and ant-man finds them and
brings them back and now they're the
fantastic four kids with these powers
that they've developed and that's such a
good
clean way to bring them into the mcu
that i personally would love to see
yeah and you can have them married
before they turned into yeah they went
in they were married her brother came
his best friend came and they're all
stuck in this thing and they all hate
read riches for it because you know he's
always the butt of all the jokes and
it's really easy to adapt that and it's
like these people didn't just show up
out of nowhere
right now now that disney's acquired it
you know right right right
there marvel will do a good job with it
whatever for sure
oh for sure uh no tracker again all day
with the super chats i love it thank you
uh i can't wait for the next lineup of
avengers
and the next behind-the-scenes villain
and how big the mcu will be in the next
in the next couple years well i
personally think secret wars is coming
and i think that's just gonna
completely shatter anything that we've
ever like
thought of because and i think
i think with i think spider-man no way
home could be that start
is when and then doctor strange
multiverse madness could like really
take it out there
and eventually you know then you have to
introduce fantastic four then you have
to introduce
you know mutants and then have the x-men
come together um which is how i hope it
happens i hope we get individual
mutants kind of like you had iron man
you had thor you had captain america and
then they became the avengers like i
hope that's how the x-men work
um hey
jasem al ali can't wait until halfway
through the movie they reveal del got
becomes a villain because tony stark cut
him off
in traffic one time
right that tony stark that tony stank
well it looks like norman osborne is
going to be the main villain
and willem dafoe is going to be one of
them and according to the hashtag show's
report
our norman is when i say our norman
osborne the mcu's norman osborne
is going to be kind of good at first
i mean i guess norman osborne is good at
first
right um and then he turns bad so i mean
i don't know is anybody
truly born bad i'm sure there are but
you know
so here's a question who
is going to play the new norman osborn i
got a list i got a list i got a list
i got a list i have to ch my fan because
it's stupid hot in here when i have all
my
lights on for live streaming if my fan
is hitting my microphone too much guys
please just let me know in the comments
comments comments write a comic book and
send it to him right now
look
okay i got a list four of them are
serious and one of them
i i i want him to be serious but i don't
think he is is that you
all right it's not me okay um
matthew mcnay would be an obvious pick
just because i think him and william the
foe would look amazing if there are two
osborns
i unless i think the unless you can
bounce off
go ahead i was gonna say unless you can
swayed me otherwise i think that's
my pick that's your first pick oh well
there you go
i'd like to see i'd like to see jude law
do it just because i think he would be a
really cool
osborne yeah only
qualm there is he's already in the mcu
yeah but not really in secret he's dead
no i'd like to see um
oh no he's not so i guess that one's out
but i would like to see him do it
um ewan mcgregor
i think he would play really cool
osborne he would actually
if you think about his character and
birds of prey
that's why i think it because him and
birds of prey is fantastic
incredible job he's so good playing that
character
um probably my favorite part of that
movie was he's incredibly good in that
movie
anyways okay i like that um i always
mispronounce go ahead go ahead go ahead
just uh i want to acknowledge another
super chat for about another one for
josem
or maybe when craven the hunter finally
appears in mcu he becomes a villain
because tony stark closed down his suit
that's a good one that's a good one uh
is nicholas cage
on your list he's not on my list but
that's just because i think he's too
old for it i mean ten years ago he would
have been a perfect pick quite frankly
yeah that's
crazy he's crazy and thanks for that
super chat again that's a good pick i
like that
but uh okay so what you matthew
mcconaughey jude law
which he's one more last name i always
mess up
um gabriel match
you know who he is he's from look him up
you'll know who he is the second you see
him
he's in suits he was rumored to be in uh
some mcu project recently i think moon
knight they said he might be moon knight
but uh he's a he's a fantastic actor he
has that
swagger of a very rich person who's in
charge
and i think he would be like a really
cool villain if they end up going that
route if he's a bad guy
interesting and then my last one and
this is going off of the theory from
your video today actually is because
you're saying he's a really good guy who
idolizes the avengers right yeah patton
oswalt can you imagine
[Music]
you know this nerdy guy who's super rich
and has this huge company and
ends up getting you know just broken
dude
that would be so cool
good norman osborn and then he's
corrupted over time
you know he becomes green goblin that'd
be super cool
i i i see so to me i see matthew
mcconaughey
oh yeah i think matthew mcconaughey and
um
willem dafoe just have an on-screen
presence together that would be awesome
yeah um i would really like to see jim
carrey
play jim carrey would be cool i think
well because there was talks that he was
talking to
uh marvel about something and so marvel
does that they kind of like talk to
everybody and they're just kind of like
yo would you want to join the mcu if we
found the perfect project for you and
they're all like yeah let's do that of
course they want to do that it's the mcu
and they're like cool i'm going to call
you in for every movie and show we have
see if there's a part that's why we get
all these rumors where it's like
oh this person's in talks to play a role
with marvel it's like yeah but like
a lot of people are um so until
until you know things are finalized it's
always pretty hard but uh i think jim
carrey would
do a good job
uh i think it would be very different
that would be very difficult osborne
but i mean have you seen the guy play
the riddler have you seen the guy play
dr eggman egghead eggman he called me
sonic calls him egghead um
robotnik robotnik dr robotnik
uh which he said was his favorite role
of all time really
yeah he absolutely fell in love with
that role i think jim carrey could play
like a
super super slick guy uh yeah jim carrey
would be a really cool pick
yeah i think that would be really really
under pat and oswald i see
yeah i see a few people i see a few
people
saying jim carrey here yeah cody
zach uh yeah jai christian slater
yeah no i could see slater i could see
christians there oh
cody castillo leonardo dicaprio
yeah that'd be really cool personally i
see it as not happening
but it would be really really cool
i think marvel would love to have leo
namco
look at the eternals it's it's
star-studded oh
turtle is insane and the amount of
secrets they've kept about that film is
insane
they've actually done a really good job
with that they did a really good job
with you know
julia louise dreyfus no one saw her they
like put her in like a harry potter
cloak
like to sneak around to the set the
whole entire time uh tiki thanks for
that super chat
do you think we can see an avengers type
movie with any game amount of heroes
including all multiverses version of the
characters yes that is secret wars
um if you haven't read that comic story
line it's amazing
i suggest you do it battle world exact
there's two secret wars battle world is
my favorite um and that's the one
that i would look into i've done a few
videos on it so just if you
go to my youtube page and type in like
cosmic wonder battle world
that should give you some good uh
insight on that but yeah that's what i
hope
the everything's leading up to like and
that's what i believe everything's
leading up to is
secret wars battle worlds uh mr anderson
hugh jackman
do you think do you think marvel would
bring you back for another
another for another character well
because you have to think about it this
way hugh jackman doesn't
i mean he's still jack right hugh
jackman
he's still jacked right now um
he he probably doesn't want to come back
and play wolverine because he's put
wolverine to rest
right and also he you know how hard he
worked out
you know how hard he worked out
to be in that
like be that ripped forward
oh man i read one time i read his
like schedule of what it was
you know when he was preparing for the
shows which i couldn't do it
i'm partially disabled but if i was i
couldn't do it
it'd be cool to see um him come in as
you know name a character and somehow
come across deadpool of deadpool like
walks away from it's just like
i don't know why but i hate that guy
[Laughter]
uh for those asking the giveaway is
going to be
at the end here um
somebody said keanu reeves i i want
canada to play doom
oh i think we can't waste keanu keano
has to play he can't waste keanu reeves
and
he's gonna play the perfect role for him
right and i and i
norman osborn's a huge deal and it's
nice that we are getting like
two uh i like william defoe's norman
osborne he's creepy
right he he's he's very creepy but he is
a sophisticated like
rich person right what if they what if
they got um
oh my gosh i can't believe i remember
anything one of my favorite actors of
all time oh i guess not then huh
what the freak is wrong with me oh i'm
gonna kill myself what is what
he's his son in the other spider-man
james franco
franco thank you how cool do you forget
that name we quote
james franco like every day um what have
i got james franco to play
man him in this mcu
that would be pretty funny actually
that'd be weird all right i got two more
for you and then i'm gonna stop
making them up mark wahlberg
because i think mark wahlberg has the
qualities
to play that character very well and
then i can't remember the other one oh
zac efron uh i can't see zac efron
i don't take that back from that
seriously
i just i don't i don't know those are my
last two i like zac griffron a lot i
wish i was him
i don't know makes me want to kill
myself i don't take him
that seriously but those are my last two
but james franco i just had that thought
just now that would be cool it'd be
really cool
we're gonna take him cool yeah it'd be
cool because it's got like that weird
multiverse kind of thing like it changes
where in this multiverse he was his son
over here in this universe he is him
well i mean he could be well
i was gonna say he could actually be
harry osborn to be in charge of oz you
know like
also no 100 possible and then he comes
and sees his son
in a different universe that would be
really cool i think that'd be about that
interesting
actually would be pretty cool like
because if he if the two green goblins
are like communicating to each other
but one is harry and he comes in and
it's like he sees the sun that would
actually be pretty cool
that'd be really trippy that would be
very very very very trippy uh
yeah i see some people saying uh zac
efron johnny storm that's what i would
like
oh luke hornson brad pitt norman osborne
he could do it brad pitt could do it
i'm still waiting for zac efron to play
him
to play johnny storm no him um
adam warlock oh oh him right him i
thought
him h.i capital him yeah
yeah that would be pretty cool too uh or
henry cavill
cavil cabell cavill whatever what it is
henry carville i think would be cool but
that's that's the big rumor right now
about about spider-man um
the big rumor right now is that they're
gonna be two spider-man
or two norman osborns they're actually
going to be like three spider-man more
than three probably
depending on how we uh look at uh john
krasinski
i i mean i if we're talking johnson i
hope he's fantastic for mr fantastic
that's just
and if for some reason he's not mr
fantastic they could find a really cool
role for him he's a strong actor
very well-liked actor there's something
for him
i think they're going to
you think i don't think he's i think
he's going to be in the mcu at some
point in time
oh for sure i think he needs to be
that's what i'm saying i think they're
going to
right not going to make him mr fantastic
although i hope i think they're going to
find a role for him
whatever that may be i thought he would
actually and
it would be kind of funny because he he
auditioned for captain america
he'd be a great captain america i think
he's like
he's big big enough for it he's he's got
like the demeanor of a steve rogers cap
like he's got the demeanor of like i'm
not shifting my morals
he's got a very strong character
personality yeah
and that's why his personality really
and he's a he's a big dude
he's a really big dude um
so i think eventually they'll put him in
the mcu somehow um some people are
saying kannaroo's ghostwriter i would
love that
i would love oh my gosh and he loves
motorcycles he's an absolute motorcycle
nut
yeah it would be perfect bernadette
andrew
uh rick grimms that's who
rick grimms sorry
he's walking dead right
looking him up yeah yeah look at him
right yeah yeah
like richards uh
yeah he's terrible he could do it no he
could do it yeah he's got the look you
could actually do an osborne
look at him really billy ray cyrus for
osborne
that be you know what's funny we were
talking about billy ray cyrus yesterday
because i was saying chris looks like
billy ray
because hillary is like really really
long hair i know he's wears a hat
chris always wears a hat and glasses and
stuff like that
um that's so that's pretty funny that's
pretty funny
um adam driver dr
doom
i kinda want doom to be older is the
only thing i want doom to be
the coolest character in mcu doom has to
be the coolest like i
if i'm so excited
if i'm if i'm like thinking about what
i'm excited for the most
i'm thinking galactus and doctor doom
like i'm most excited for the villains
mads mickelson play doctor i know the
name but i don't oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah and he's the new uh
grindelwald right yeah yeah yeah i would
love
he's actually going to be an indiana
jones too this guy doesn't sleep vince
yeah oh yeah yeah vincent's kingpin
versus tom hall and spider-man take you
thanks for super chat i would love to
see that
um see miles mariotti is in spite of
three and who would i cast as
miles morales um
well child just can't be noticed his
uncle already and
his prowler but i would really love to
see him but he's too old is the thing
um i've said it before in the past who
have i said i can't remember who i said
i'd like to see
cast as him oh that's gonna bug me
oh that's gonna bug me if i think of it
i'll let you know um
i think he's gonna be set up in
spider-man 3 i don't know if we'll see
him
what's the name of the guy from stranger
things
i'm not going to be able to tell you
that but kayla it's kayla it's caleb
something look up kayla
mc laughlin laughing hold on real fast
he looks just like him oh really daniel
thanks for the super chat gun carlo
esposito
be a good one i actually for norman
osborne unlikely you get to roll but who
knows
he knows how to play the bad guy and
everything nowadays that's true not
wrong
not wrong i think that's a good choice
who am i looking up
uh caleb yeah yeah yeah they're saying
caleb mclaughlin that's the one that
might have been who i said before in the
past
he looks just like miles
well i said the pr yes no that's yeah
that's absolutely him
oh yeah that is the kid for strangers
yeah he looks just like him that'd be a
great pick he looks just like he's a
good actor he's been acting since
his attitude is kind of like him too
looks kind of goofy like in a way oh
yeah super
super duper that's why yeah i talked
about that in one video yeah i think he
would make a really good miles morales
um for you know the one he looks like
him but i mean you're in a suit you
don't necessarily have to look like
miles
right uh but his attitude like how he is
like his personality would be like
pretty good
so yeah absolutely that'd be a great
pick oh i forgot about michael
fassbender
he could do norman he could do norman
osborn
i just wonder if marvel
worries about already being famous
not that i i wonder if they worry about
the old fox stuff whoops i could see him
playing doom
who might be fassbender i would love it
but i
was just wondering if if they worry that
everyone's going to think oh
isn't this guy magneto you know what i
mean like i wonder if marvel cares
about because he's a fantastic fantastic
i'm sure they do
of course they do uh hey jorge
or george i'm sorry if i don't pronounce
that right man
monet uh daiquiri meter is johnny storm
yeah i've seen so much fan art of that
and i think it would be incredible
so but that's what's up that's what's
coming up oh liam neeson has galactus
heck yeah man
that would be so he's got the voice to
be galactus right you can see jai
whatever you need to do but
that that's gonna be awesome so well all
right guys
i think the two norman osborne's coming
in spider-man 3 as reported by the
hashtag show would be super cool
uh because i would love to see willem
dafoe back and i would love a new one
and i think we've talked about a lot of
people
who i mean one of them has to be right
maybe right you will i'm gonna post this
after we'll leave this up one one
maybe one of the people we talked about
i think matthew mcconaughey would be a
good one i think we've talked about a
lot of good people
pat and oswalt that's already here
that's our pitch
to play when
but uh hey shield
shield guess what warren chicken butt
the winner the winner is currently in
the chat
oh really
who's the winner in the chat you've been
commenting i don't know
um we randomly picked the winner before
we went live guys
and i have seen the winner comment
multiple times during this chat so i
wonder if you're still here really i ha
i haven't been we've given away
something live so
we've never done an announcement for a
giveaway winner live though and
i i
i get sad when i do giveaways because we
only there's only one winner right and
which is why i gave the funko pops away
for a long time
so i could do more um
because i get sad that like i can't give
everybody one but
i don't have that money i'm not norman
osborne
can't confirm the winner is currently in
chat i just saw them say something
they actually asked oh i see they
actually asked who it was
i see yeah
all right chris you want to do an honors
do you want me to say it i don't know
how to pronounce
i don't know how to pronounce your name
all right here we go you ready guys
congratulations to teague tozer for
winning the giveaway
i would have said tag which one is is it
teague or tag
team it's teague is that i've chat with
him in live in live streams yeah it is
teague
congratulations buddy you were the
random winner of the captain america
shield
giveaway i actually had it up here hold
on
i actually had it ready to post because
we
we drew the name yeah yeah
has he commented again yet not since we
said it
wait what i didn't i was not expecting
it there you go t congratulations
it's the first live giveaway i've ever
done i actually like that
um that's actually pretty cool again
sorry i can't give it to everybody but
we're gonna do more
we're gonna do what this is the last
captain shield i have on me but i can
order them from amazon
so go ahead and put what you would like
the next giveaway to be um oh yeah we're
doing more guys we're doing we're gonna
do more i stopped doing that for a while
i don't know if you guys noticed i
stopped doing like big giveaways and
that's because
i kind of like i didn't want people to
follow me for the giveaways but then i
thought i was like well i'm
that's really screwed up to my actual
subscribers already
so i do the giveaways now you know to
give them to you guys not to get more
followers but
i'm gonna do more and i'm going to
start doing smaller ones too so we can
just do more like cool like the funko
pops and stuff like that but uh go ahead
and comment down below what you guys
like to see thor's hammer so
i have a mjolnir and stormbreaker
yeah right there the stormbreaker is
really cool guys like it
it's really really cool if you can see
it i'll get out of the way but it it's
so cool
we opened it not on our last year all
right i see a ton of people seeing
stormbreaker hold on let me grab
stormbreaker
we were playing with it for a while
because this thing is like
seriously cool this thing is seriously
cool it's freaking huge
it it lights up
it's insanely cool it makes and then
when you move it
it lights up it does different things
when you move it right so
it's like so cool let's show you guys a
little bit of it
my lights are all like on it so you
can't like see it right but
it lights up it's extremely detailed
it's extremely detailed it's got riding
like on the sides it's got norse on it
it's got norse on the back
lights all right i think chad has spoken
i think stormbreaker is going to be in
the next giveaway
so really really i think yeah this will
definitely be the most
expensive piece i've ever given away
right
give away plays playstation 5 once oh i
have given away
playstation fives and xboxes a lot just
kidding not not not the most expensive
thing i've done
uh so people who were talking about the
black panther helmet
man i have been looking and maybe it's
different now
all right stormbreaker calm down go to
bed
um man i've been looking and since chad
book passed away
they're super rare or they're like 500
or something like that
um i mean like really the star-lord
helmet's pretty hard to find too they
didn't make a lot
star-lord one they don't make a lot of
for some reason
uh probably because they're not as
purchased hey
cut it out stormbreaker
it's just going off though
oh yeah so i forgot when you lay storm
breaker down
that's oh i oh yeah i forgot chris i
need to bring chris back that's on me
i'm gone you're gone
evidently people like you guys if you
haven't subscribed to chris's channel
cosmic culture go
subscribe uh that's how you enter some
of the giveaways chris is actually two
room
a room over he's down the hall for me
right now you can run and say hi
what was that what is that noise wait
chris you pressed something
crash
he pressed something on his screen and
then he left to come to my room hey you
pressed something on your computer
and it made a lot of noise yeah it was
it's like a trailer or something
oh it's halo i can hear the o's well you
didn't say
hi
can you all hear halo
[Music]
i don't think it's me is it me
it's not me oh it is me that's on me
go away halo no go away
no stop it
that's my bad
[Laughter]
look it's chris oh he's behind me now
so all right guys stormbreaker is
looking to be next you can just say
goodbye right here
this i mean this it's it's heavy look
how long it is right i mean it's
it's big right i mean it's it's it's
really cool
it's it's a really cool thing and uh
yeah i'll give uh
i'll give these away because it's cool i
want i want some of y'all to have it
we'll do a few
how about that we'll give a few ones so
up chris is back
all right you're going to sleep
stormbreaker but all right guys
uh congrats again to how do you say it
uh teague teague we got to get fatigue
um we know how to contact you
uh chris why don't you do that right now
go check some of your old comments i
told you how to get and touch him there
you go teague yeah we uh we don't like
giving
emails away out loud because then we get
spammed
so in the giveaways uh i'm not gonna
give this one away for those who say i'm
not giving mine away i'll order it right
from amazon to your house
that's the except for this shield which
will actually be coming directly from
this shield will be there will be this
shield
right here that's actually going to be
coming directly from me
so um yeah but uh t congratulations
and guys we're going gonna be doing the
live streams uh probably thursdays we
weren't feeling too good yesterday so
it's today
uh but probably thursday is just not you
know like one in the morning
yeah they've been fun they've been all
fun the live streams are super fun
uh the late ones that we've been doing
for the show so we just wanted to keep
them going because it's awesome to talk
to everybody
and chris got a new toy this is my
favorite funko pop of all time
it's the spiderman is it called the
imposter one oh no
spiderman it's called spiderman vs
spider-man yeah
so all right guys hope everyone has a
good day big shout out to mr anderson
for being an awesome mod it looks like
he was pretty busy today
but uh thanks everybody for coming by i
appreciate all the chats i appreciate
anybody that's just
sitting there watching for entertainment
or maybe not entertainment maybe you
weren't unchanged
but thank you everybody for the support
we both love you so much uh be sure to
subscribe to
cosmic culture to chris over here and
the other channel that i'm on as well
um and we'll be seeing you guys next
week i would say expect it thursday
probably around the same time so love
you all
see you next time oh wait i'm on my